et
[Musique]
pour voir si le nouveau système de
numérotation shadoks tenait debout nous
vous avions poser un petit problème
voyons quelle est la solution
il y aura un autre problème à la fin de
l'émission voilà le nombre shadoks
traduit en français beaucoup de nos
téléspectateurs avaient trouvé mais pas
mal de shadocks aussi il faut avouer et
oui le système du professeur shadow
comarch s était gagné les shadoks
maintenance avait coûté grisé par le
succès le professeur continue son cours
magistral et s'attaque aujourd'hui à la
réforme de la juge m hocine géométrie
shadoks reposait sur un postulat assez
bizarre qui disait courroye la ligne
droite est le plus long chemin d'un
point à un autre et vous conviendrez que
pour les voyages interstellaires ça
risquait de poser des difficultés mais
grâce à shadow co tout cela ait changé
écoutons le premier par le poids des
finitions le point est la plus courte
distance possible entre du lied première
application étant données de l'ign
quelconque trouver l'endroit où elle se
coupe
supposons qu'elle se rend compte en zoo
et émeut par exemple si l'on est ainsi
d'après notre définition la ligne au me
serais un point et serait plus courte
que le point but or ce n'est pas le cas
donc les lignes se rencontrent en bus
dotés or m
deux lignes qui se rencontrent se
rencontrent toujours au même endroit
propriétés remarquables tout ligne
prises hors d'un point ne passe pas par
ce point ou alors si elle y passe c'est
vraiment par hasard
deuxièmement les points parallèle on dit
qu'un point est parallèle à deux autres
points lorsque ce point est en
convenablement disposer si on le déplace
d'un côté ou de l'autre
il est plus parallèle d'où théorème la
condition suffisante pour qu'un point
reste bien parallèles à deux autres
points et qu'il reste là où il est et
qu'il ne bouge pas en deuxième partie
d'année on appelle ligne de premier
choix les lignes qui ne passe que par
des points parallèle on appelle l' in
shadow coup ligne encombrante les lignes
qui passe plusieurs fois par un même
point ou par plusieurs on appelle ligne
de deuxième catégorie des lignes qui
arrive sur un point qui s'arrête on
appelle ligne deux dernières catégories
ou petites lignes les lignes qui ne
passe que par un seul point
et maintenant un petit exercice de
mathématiques shadow si un chat 2 que
court le long d'une ligne de premier
choix parcours dit shadoks mettre à
l'heure combien mettra type de temps
pour parcourir 11 jadot pertes
la réponse dans notre prochain numéro
[Musique]